[Música]
el quarterback de los tampa bay
buccaneers son brady y considerado el
mejor jugador de la historia de la nfl
anunció su retirada después de 22
temporadas eso publica su decisión a
través de una carta que difundió en su
cuenta de instagram abro comillas y dijo
he reflexionado y me he hecho preguntas
difíciles creo que los aficionados
merecen el 100% de mí pero en este
momento es mejor que deje el campo de
juego la próxima generación de jugadores
comprometidos son brady terminó la
temporada del 21 como el número 1 en
yardas con
5.316 y con más anotaciones son 43 decía
que quería jugar más allá de los 45 años
pero finalmente su carrera llegó al
final en a filas de la franquicia de los
tampa con quien levantó el super bowl el
año pasado para ello quiero saludar
entonces a nuestro segundo invitado el
es de pávlovich venga él es comentarista
de la nfl de la cadena de deportes y
espn gracias pablo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
y quiero preguntarles es realmente tom
brady el mejor de todos los tiempos
sin duda raúl es algo con mucho gusto si
es esa discusión termino yo te diría
desde hace algunos años la comparación o
el comparativo o el análisis era con joe
montana porque yo montana llego a super
bowl lo hizo de manera magistral 4 con
el equipo de san francisco y era que el
core back regresaba en los últimos
instantes para poner a su equipo en un
en un super bowl y ganarlo y barco toda
una época en los ochentas con el equipo
de los polis nine ers sin embargo llega
tom brady y tom brady pues en la mitad
de los 22 años que jugó prácticamente la
mitad llega y es super bowl siete
títulos siete triunfos doce con dos
equipos distintos y sobre todo yo creo
que el punto más alto en donde se
termina esta discusión de si es el más
grande o no de la historia fue en aquel
súper bowl donde estaba abajo en el
marcador por 21 puntos regresó el
partido se fue a tiempo extra lo conocen
muy bien contra planta y sacó ese
partido saco 'super bowl' en uno de los
más grandes regresos que se han visto en
la historia de la nfl ahora pablo les
faltaron logros o realmente ya con todo
lo que hizo que no es menos por supuesto
ya cumplió con lo que tenía que hacer
no no el mayo te diría que hasta les
sobraron les sobraron porque fue un
jugador que pues nadie se puede imaginar
que en una liga tan demandante tan
competitiva en un deporte donde es muy
físico donde cierto es que las reglas
hoy en día favorecen a los ofensivos y
protegen mucho a los core back pero
también es un deporte donde los
jugadores año con año llegan más rápidos
más fuertes más pesados y el promedio de
vida de un jugador es de tres años brady
jugó hasta los 44 años de edad en dos
temporadas
entonces hizo cualquier cantidad de
récords de marcas y lo más impresionante
es raúl es que lo seguía haciendo no es
que acabó dando lástima no es que el
deporte lo acabo por retirar porque
físicamente no podía no se mantuvo a un
altísimo nivel todavía es que pablo de
eso sobre todo le quería hablar porque
fueron 22 temporadas que lo hemos
jugando en este fútbol profesional y
siete de ellas se hizo con un superbowl
que lo hizo tan exitoso cuál fue el
éxito de brady
se combinan varias cosas raúl no
solamente es el talento de 'break' eso
es uno de los puntos más importantes
esto hay que ser talentoso pero en el
aspecto individual está el talento está
la preparación y está la dedicación la
ayer yo escuchaba un ex jugador de la
nfl comentarista nuestro ni despiden y
decía todos se fijan lo que hacemos los
domingos claro es el día del juego
estamos bajo los reflectores nadie se
fija lo que hacemos de lunes a viernes
en preparar nuestro cuerpo en preparar
un partido en físicamente ir a los
campos de entrenamiento
las pesas al gimnasio al prepararte
pared y de partido pri lo hacía perfecto
toda la semana y el día del juego
también lo hacías y entonces esa es la
parte individual hay que estar
plenamente está no preparado y enfrentar
un partido con el mejor estudio y por el
lado colectivo por el lado de equipo se
combinan cosas un muy buen entrenador
como bill belichick una buena gerencia
general que supo manejar hay que
recordar en la nfl hay un tope salarial
y entonces tienes que jugar para tratar
de mantener a tus mejores jugadores y
siempre está rodeado de un buen equipo y
todo eso se convino para quebrar y
tuviera tanto éxito en la nfl ahora fue
un buen momento para su retirada digamos
se retiró en la cima no a sus 44 años le
preguntó habría alguna posibilidad de su
regreso o no es posible
no yo creo que no no el si bien es
cierto había manifestado que quería
jugar hasta los 45 le faltó una
temporada pero yo creo que brady lo deja
claro hace un par de semanas en uno de
sus post que en su podcast let's go
junto con el periodista en inglés tim
bray él dice empieza a enfocarme en la
familia y cuando un jugador de tantos
años en un deporte profesional empieza a
hablar de que sus prioridades son la
familia el estar más tiempo con la
familia no es que antes no lo haya sido
desde luego verdad el empezar a ver otro
tipo de cosas no dejar a un lado brady
es un empresario brain y es una empresa
que genera millones de dólares cada año
no hablemos de la esposa que también
genera muchísimo mucho más que brain
pero entonces brady tiene un método que
es el habitual del cual se quiere
enfocar más tiene una muy buena relación
con la marca ondero armor de la cual
seguramente habrán habrá cosas por por
venir entonces yo creo que las
prioridades de brady y lo que él decía
en esa declaración que tú se
dimensionaba raúl él no está
plenamente enfocado como un jugador
debería de estar porque hay otras
distracciones veíamos en estas imágenes
quién está corriendo a un lado de él y
su hijo tu hijo que tuvo con su primer
pareja y pues él manifestaba que quiere
pasar más tiempo con su hijo y con él
pues el resto de su familia no ahora
pablo el 13 de febrero comienza este
nuevo super bowl sin la presencia de tom
brady cómo queda el deporte y también le
quiero preguntar por supuesto si hay
alguien que se perfilen oa seguir los
pasos de the brady para que sea la nueva
estrella de la nfl
bueno primero obviamente va a ser un
superbowl o extraño porque porque no es
que no es que es no es que necesitamos
abrir y lo que pasa es que en otros años
a días de que bueno no estaba previa
pero no se preocupen regresará
seguramente algún año va a regresar
verdad ahora ya vas a enfrentar una nfl
brady yo creo que es un sentimiento muy
parecido a lo que ocurrió con la nba
cuando se fue michael jordan o cuando
venga la siguiente temporada y veas que
ninguno de los rosters o al menos en el
de tampa bay no está el número 12 y
brady pues entonces sí se ve extrañar
las nuevas caras de la nfl tienen a
jugadores como patrick bach oms como yo
salen como el mismo tubo lo que va a
jugar el super bowl ahora con el
cincinnati como la mark dayton como
justin herbert son jugadores que están
pues en un promedio de 24 o 25 años de
edad que son muy talentosos que han
empezado a obtener
triunfos en el caso de patrick makau ya
62 superbowls entonces no sé si raúl al
alcance para llegar a los logros de
pride y no veo difícil que lo podamos
ver en vida a nosotros pero incluso
serán las caras de la nfl vamos a ver
entonces qué pasa quién se perfilará y
quien le pueda podrá llegar un poco a
los salones del programa home a lo mejor
que tuvo una extraordinaria temporada el
año pasado gracias pablo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de frank 104
y conversar sobre este deporte que lo
apasiona